yes yes what's happening this is my like
for like
my range rover's in the garage this is
my like for like replacement car anyway
this is andrew how you doing bro
yeah good i'm excited ready
ready for winners on the website
interview so welcome to my crib come on
round
let's go three two one here we go
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome to another winners on a
wednesday this guy is called andre he's
21
he's financially free andrew you always
said you're gonna be sitting here
on my sofa when it's on a wednesday i
did i said i'm gonna sit on this seat
right here and i
am here now so this is like um a vision
board
happening now yes i visualized it and
now i made it happen
so you didn't take you haven't got hard
feelings about me evicting you
no no not at all i learned a lot from it
and i went and took action and obviously
i am where i am now now we first met
uh i think there was a dinner that
happened maybe a year ago
and at that time you know you came down
to this dinner
we bumped into each other very very
briefly you were watching all of my
youtube videos you're like man i'm
watching the videos i read all the books
i'm listening to the podcasts
you you were getting so much information
but you weren't getting any results yeah
that's true um the first year out
when i started learning about property i
spent the whole year
watching videos reading books mostly
your videos
they were interested in me so i had all
this information stored
in my head but i wasn't taking action on
any of it i thought i needed to learn
more
i kept thinking if i carried on you
could always learn more
if you don't take the action you're not
going to get no results and the thing is
though when you came on the eviction
even
you know the [ __ ] that the show the
youtube show you were like
you telling me you've been phoning
agents you'd made loads of calls
you even had taken action yeah so
that's after the first year then i
started um
taking action i'd say how many years
have you spent thinking about doing this
you're 21 man on the second year i
started taking
massive action i was working 18 hour
days doing what
um property sourcing so i had built up
200 investors in a month
right but then i got no deals for the
investors
um the main issue was i was
making loads of phone calls to agents
i've made way over 10 000 calls
throughout
my journey geez but i
i was following i would say
i wasn't following up with these agents
i wasn't
closing i was getting them close to the
point of closing but i wasn't closing i
didn't know how to close
um so you knew you knew the theory
i knew the power into rent works of how
a lease option worked
yeah but you didn't know how to actually
do a deal that's right yeah
why don't you just want you just pay and
do my lease option boot camp and stuff
well see i when i came into property
i'll be honest i thought um a lot of
these courses they just want to take my
money
right and um i i didn't really think i'm
gonna get
what the value for the money that
i didn't it's more self-belief to be
honest it's self-esteem everything comes
down to self-esteem
when you have enough self-esteem you
take you know what though
the lie of the i don't know who they are
the losers yeah that says you don't
don't pay for training you can just get
it for free online
that lot i used to just think stupid
but now it bothers me because i think
you're
robbing people's success like you're
living proof if you just try and do the
free stuff
and go online and watch videos and etc
and
listen to podcasts and read books and
have a bash without proper support
proper training being in the right
environment
being professionally supported you're
gonna get blown flat
yeah no that's guaranteed blown flat
guaranteed that happened to me
i'm living proof of that happening i've
made so many calls i've i've done so
so much i've put so much effort in
18-hour days for a year
i done so i was only sleeping six hours
and crazy and you didn't get sick i
didn't get a single deal
that must have been demoralizing i i
didn't have the steps i didn't i wasn't
shown how to do it so i'm just trying to
get all this information from reading
books and and someone says something
else someone else says something else
i think you need to find a mentor that
you want to be like someone who you can
see that's getting results
yeah and then stick with that one person
you know what i think you're right
because you can also you can google
something
you know like if you google how to
get a rent to rent contract what's going
to come up all these different things
yeah if you google
you know how to do a rent to rent you
you're going to get
websites written by kids or written by
people that know what they're talking
about you know you might end up on some
terrible website someone's saying
retweets don't even work
yeah it's like all this different
conflicting advice you know you're right
um i mean as it happens as it happens
you spent the first year not taking any
action obviously you're not going to get
results
second you're taking loads of action how
how did it feel
one year into working 18 hour days
i mean how would you say do you mean
your job on top of property
no i only worked on property so i had
i literally was working whilst i'm
eating food and
i i'm known from the people that know me
as someone who's extremely crazy
at uh so you were literally how were you
affording to
live well i live my family so i don't
have any expertise what did your parents
think of you doing that
they thought i'm crazy yeah yeah and you
probably were
i was yeah so you were spending 18 hours
a day
taking action off the back of reading
books and listening to youtube videos
and after a year you thought
i need to do something else yeah for the
eviction
that that's that's definitely it yeah i
mean when you came on the edition how
many deals have you done
on the eviction no when you were
so i had sourced to rent to rent deals
um so i met up with someone who had
deals so
i knew what he was looking for and he
sort of was guiding me as well
so i had source two rent to rent deals
then i obviously applied for the
eviction
when you say you sold 200 deals you
found them and you sold them i found
them a soldier how much do you make
i made a thousand pound in total so 500
500 deal so you got ripped off
yeah i i did get uh help from that
individual
mentoring in return so it's sort of yeah
yeah that's right yeah all right fine
then you applied for the eviction then
apply
meet mr samuel leeds
i knew i knew what i needed to do to get
on the eviction
i'm like you went crazy bro you are
harassing me at one time i was thinking
of calling the po-po
i need to call the police on this dude i
had 127 comments just on my instagram
dude
to me you were you were messaging me you
were getting everyone to tag me in your
your stuff i was like who is this dude
i met you one time one time very briefly
at dinner but even then
you pay for the dinner you only got to
go to the dinner by doing the same
harassment techniques yeah remember
that's right yeah what happened
how did we first make what happened with
that well you had put on a
winners on a wednesday dinner and you
were inviting someone to come along so
um i think it was to make a post um
tagging you and writing a comment
did i do a giveaway yeah you were doing
the giveaway thousand comments
i'm getting this i'm in my head with my
mindset i'm like there's no way
on earth i'm not going there you know
what though in all seriousness when i
saw
you posting regularly obviously i'm kind
of kidding you weren't actually
harassing me
but when i saw how much effort you're
putting into it and how many people you
were getting to tag and you're sharing
stuff and i was getting tagged all the
time andrew
andrew andre you know i actually i
actually saw that as
you know hunger i saw that as someone
that's prepared to put themselves out
there
and that's why you know i said i said i
said i put a good word and i was like
maybe you know you need to check this
kid out
um next thing i know you're on the
eviction
um what was that like when you when you
first started doing the eviction
that that was great um like i i was used
to working long hours working hard
but it's the hours that i put in were
more effective
i actually got a deal agreed on the
eviction for the lease option
well you were you went through the lease
option boot camp as part of the eviction
yeah
which was and people think the lease
option boot camp is just going to be me
talking talking talking talking
no 50 hours majority of the time what
were you doing
i was taking action out on the road oh
on the road yeah going everywhere
right so what happened you secured a
lease option
i secured a lease option i've still in
communication with
one of the people i spoke to one of the
landlords
who actually have seven properties that
they want to give me
um bless you
yes i'm still in communication with one
of the landlords that from the eviction
who actually have seven properties that
they want to give me
um and i know they they work all of them
work um
yeah lease option agreements yeah okay
they're just waiting for
uh they're just waiting for the covert
situation to
slow down um so when the market picks up
and stuff
then they they want to uh agree a deal
with me
for seven of their properties awesome
awesome
what was the biggest thing that you
learned on the lease option boot camp
that shifted things because since then
you've gone to become financially free
we'll talk about that and what deals
you've done
what was the shift what was the thing
that you learned or the thing that
happened or the thing that you saw
what changed the main shift was
going direct to landlords okay so
before as i said i've made all these
calls they were all through agents and
even if i had a deal
i couldn't pass reference and i couldn't
get the deal sure
so you were hitting a brick wall which
was number one
you were contacting agents and they
weren't taking you seriously
but then the odd one that would finally
come through they'd say we need your
references and then they go oh you're
not working you got no job you got no
money
close so what you you were like climbing
the wrong ladder
yeah so so so you then shifted that
right
yeah i mean it was uh when i went direct
to landlords
the second i had a view in booked in
within a matter of what was it within
the same day of doing the the boot camp
uh lease option boot camp
i knew that i can definitely do this for
the rent to rent as well
so in my mind i'm like as soon as i get
out of this eviction
i thought i was going to win anyway but
as soon as i get out the eviction i'm
gonna
get my rent to rent deals going direct
to landlords it was much easier
because i've practiced pitching uh
agents
so for so long so speaking to a landlord
and pitching was very easy for me
yeah so here we go this is potentially
for people watching
gonna save them a year's worth of
anguish
right now so if you are 20 years old and
you haven't got any money or any income
trying to get a rent to rent from an
agent might be difficult
yeah so another angle would be to go and
speak to a vendor direct
where did you learn to find vendors
direct
and what did you learn to say so
as i said on the lease option um when in
the eviction when we were doing the
lease options
um that's when us uh first started
actually calling
vendors direct on guntree on gumtree
right
so gumtree and gumtree is is just what
like what is gumtree like a website
where yourself what stuff
yeah people sell all sorts of items uh
they rent their property sell their
properties on gumtree
that's where you find motivated sellers
and motivated people to arrest you
gotta be pretty mother to put your house
on gumtree yeah it's like
it didn't work with an agent i'm
motivated
put it on gum tray and then when you
phone up what are you saying
when i phone up i first i start off
asking about the property and
the condition it's in then i get into
that i run a corporate let company and
i'll fully manage the property take it
off their hands
i think you need to just explain the
good points
about rent to rent to the landlords
before just going at them with all this
information because
as soon as you mention company letter if
you go in saying hi i'm andre i
run a company let turn off they're gonna
but if you go in there genuinely
speaking to them building a bit of
report
and um i say
slowly tell them the benefits of a rent
to rent
um taking off their hand guaranteeing
their rent and fully managing their
property
then they're more willing to work with
you yeah and if
if they're not if they're still unsure
what i do is i book in
a viewing and i say okay meet me in
person
and then you can see what what kind of
person i am if you want to work with me
we can we can work together um another
big tip i'd say for young people is
because a lot of landlords don't want to
work with young people that's
just the truth because you look young
they don't want to work with you yeah a
big tip uh
something that functioned for me with
these two rent to rent deals i took on
was i bring my parents with me to the
viewing
right and then we're gonna get on to
that when we talk about your
your rental rents that you see but yeah
go on go on so you're initially speaking
to a landlord
you're young how does that hinder you i
mean
you're on the phone well i didn't have a
beard back then but
on the phone they don't know how old you
are so you can
you can speak to them that's not the
issue i'd say
closing the deal where you have to go to
meet them yeah um
i'd recommend bringing someone older
with you or grow beard or grow a beard
if you can right so going back to this
point right so
ringing people on gumtree is smart
because the
hat it's direct to vendor they're
motivated where else could you find
directive and or
opportunities well you could go on a
spare room yep uh um
you've got open rent yep but mainly i
i personally like gumtree
of different foreign there's loads of
platforms where you can contact the
owner direct
you don't need an agent that's going to
go well actually we need this
this this is right because that now is
relationship building
now it's about as you said before so
okay so on the eviction you got a lease
option agreement different things
which was kind of part of training what
happened with the lease option agreement
that you secured on the eviction
well with that um i'll be honest with
you i've kind of
let it i didn't follow up with it
um i did speak to them they they had
said they want to speak to their
solicitor
so when they spoke to their solicitor
apparently they didn't recommend
um working doing a lease option
so that was the if i had followed up and
maybe got them in touch with
one of our the solicitors that do lease
options
i maybe would have got it so do you feel
that you kind of messed up on that a
little bit
i did yeah you dropped the ball maybe
because you were busy with like the
training and you were going off to do
yeah but but what happened and we get a
lesson in this so you secured the deal
you got the memorandum of understanding
secured and signed yes the memorandum of
understanding
in my experience once you get that
signed the deal has a 90
chance of going through it yeah you just
got that signed
awesome then what happened was you
dropped the ball a little bit
the vendor went and spoke to their
solicitor when you probably should take
in a bit more control
and said hey great here's how this is
going to work let me put you in touch
with a sister and you put them in touch
with your sister yeah
but no big deal it's a learning it's a
learning curve
after the eviction you went and secured
a couple of beautiful juicy renter rents
which i've been out to i've seen
yeah i saw them just after you got them
before they were filled
talk to me about how you got those deals
tell me
what happened tell me the story so when
i left the eviction
um i'd say not even a week in a week's
time
i went on to gumtree um i i took off two
three days
to sort of settle down from the eviction
it was quite intense
were you were you emotional when you got
evicted i was yeah very upset
i was very upset um i genuinely believed
i'm
definitely going to win this and i am
the type of person
i i want to win at everything i do yeah
and
but yeah it's still the learning curve
from it
was enough to get me and also when you
got evicted
you know out this you're you're in my
dining room yeah i said you're evicted
and you left you even said as you're
leaving i'm gonna be back on winners on
the wednesday
i did i haven't lost i've won my
property game i'm gonna
i'm gonna win but maybe just not in the
form that i thought i would on the
eviction
yeah but yeah we had that conversation
uh right after
i was emotional but i said to you i'm
gonna what i'm gonna get these deals
well i'm gonna get some deals and i'm
going to be sitting on this seat that
i'm sitting right now yeah
was i nice to see you after aft after
the cameras went off
uh sorry say that well that was nice to
when the cameras went off yeah yeah
that's good i remember the when when you
gathered everyone
uh so when i walked in the kitchen
everyone's clapping
yeah for me that was a good feeling yeah
yeah yeah because on camera it can be a
bit rough you know like you're evicted
and it's a bit well but
when the cameras go off it's a bit nicer
yeah definitely you know
so okay so you get out of the eviction
you had a couple days to just
you know mourn and grieve that you got
evicted and then what happened
then i went on to gumtree and i was i
was just
calling up every single lead that was on
there
to be honest i only took me 10 calls
um to agree or deal with this
with this landlord um two deals actually
because it's two
two properties that she has so i had
uh spoken to them they didn't want to
work with me at the start that's the
truth
um i had to sort of build rapport um
and get them to to be what are they
how did you know they didn't know where
were you they they didn't want a
company first of all because they had a
company right uh before
i i took them on and they had a bad
experience yeah
they sort of used it for different
purpose not for rent to rent
oh wow so and that that was the issue
that
that landlord had yeah um
but i i managed to i spoke to them i
said
look can i meet you at the property i
i'll do a viewing you can see
what type of person i'm i'll explain how
it all works and what i'm going to do
okay and when i went to the viewing
i could instantly tell that there
when they saw me i had no beard i was
looking like a
14 year old um they did they
wasn't because they're old they were in
their seventies
i thought you were a kid they saw me as
a kid they saw me as
someone uh starting out um he's gonna
make a lot of mistakes he might not pay
my rent
um all these questions in their head
but i managed to speak to them in a
professional way
they and then the main thing was i bring
my parents
yeah you said that so you brought your
mom and your dad yeah i brought my mom
and my dad was that awkward or was that
fine
no it was fine um i bring them with me
and just so they could see i'm a family
person i'm someone who's going to pay
their rent so they feel more comfortable
with me and not just
just a kid starting out so
they spoke to my parents my parents
spoke to them
had this communication built report and
then the next day i called him up i say
let's close let's close this deal and
they agreed i went there signed the
papers took the keys
and what paperwork did you use
well they didn't want to use my contract
so
she the landlord had actually found
an agency that has a contract
so i used their contract what period
what time period is it over the
timescale it's
two years with the option to extend for
another five years
um if obviously i may manage the
property well
cool so soon as long as you've done a
decent job yeah wow that's
that'll be a seven year in total worst
case two years if you mess it up yeah
um how much money was needed to secure
these two
rent to end properties and how much
profit are you making from them
so i paid a 1 000 pound deposit per
uh flat so that's 2 000 in total yeah
and the refurb works i'd say
we're about just under two grand
okay um but with with the dressings and
the furniture
it came up to about four grand in total
that's right
but those dressings i'm going to reuse
for my other properties so sort of a
business expense rather than a
it was not crazy money but it's not
quite an investment
yeah you know considering you've not got
an income you didn't have an income
coming in at the time
um so you get these two properties what
are they
and how much money are they making so
it's two rent to rent deals
um in the same area uh same building
i've secured the whole building
and i'm making uh 1 600
net profit per month that's incredible
so you're making 1 600 and they're two
large
apartments yeah and how many bedrooms
um uh four beds two four beds two four
bed apartments
so you're paying the landlord landlady a
guaranteed rent for the two apartments
yep but then you've then rented it out
as a multi-let and you're renting on a
room by room basis
yes that's right yeah what are the rules
in terms of licensing
planning permission all that stuff well
in hounslord council which is in hansler
council
if it's three or more occupants you need
additional licensing
but because i wanted to put a couple in
so i can charge a bit more
i applied for mandatory licensing which
is
five uh up to five uh occupants
in the property so yeah i mean you just
go on the hansler website write hmo
license
send an application form so you've got a
license for it then
i've applied for the license but you
don't have to wait to be able to don't
have to wait no
that's a really interesting point though
that people probably don't don't realize
when you apply for a hmo license it can
take a long time to get it approved yeah
but you don't have to wait until it's
approved to start renting out the rooms
you can start renting other rooms from
the moment you apply
yeah that's right so that's what i've
done actually so i've
um i i just applied for it straight away
done the works and
um then i'm fully tenanted now how do
you know
whether it will be definitely approved
or not well i'll check if it's in the
article
four area um so it wasn't in an article
four um
i i had a look into it and i
i know what i need to do in terms of the
refurbs and the property
to get it licensed but even then if if
there's something that's missing
they will come and tell you oh you need
to get this fixed you need to get this
fixed
and that's the thing as well people
don't realize again but when you're
turning a property into a hmo
on the council website it will give you
a real clear breakdown guide of exactly
what the property needs in order to be
licensable so you just read that
make sure that it's done to that
standard you've spent a few thousand
refurbishing it yeah
furnishing yeah making it nice and
appropriate applied for the license
mix out the rooms how quickly did it
take to rent the rooms out in this
current market with the economy being a
bit
funny what was that like so december
um before the refurbs even started i
tenanted one
uh one room um i took it on on the 28th
of november when i took the property on
um on december the first i took
i got one tenant so three days later
i've actually taken the property
um december then the rest of it was all
doing the refurb works and i wasn't
really
getting much viewings then especially
because it's december's the slowest
month of the year
and then from january also towards the
end of december january
um i had rented five rooms in four days
and i had rented all my rooms within two
weeks after the refurbs were done
less than two weeks that's actually very
very fast so what you did
again which was smart was you started
marketing the prop the rooms
before they were quite ready yeah and
you also
marketed them in an interesting way yes
i did yeah yeah
well um if when i was marketing
justin chiswick for example i might get
two messages maybe three messages a day
but that wasn't enough i had eight rooms
to fill so i needed to bring
all the attention so i had put multiple
adverts i put one in
turn and green i'd put one in um acton
all
around the area that's close to my
property
i put adverts out and dummy ads so then
when people requested
a viewing for another area like turning
green
i'll say sorry but that property is gone
however i've got this one in chiswick
would you like to view it and i'll show
them the the real pictures of
the property and they'll say yes i
actually got free tenants like that
so they're ringing about a property in
an area in that because they're ringing
get them on the phone get their
attention and then you're saying you
know what unfortunately that one's not
available but there is one five minutes
down the road
and then you just sell them on it yeah
sales skills are really important as
well i mean what you're talking about is
marketing
and um i mean you know i wouldn't
necessarily
endorse that that that way of doing it
yeah because i'm not sure how sparing
would feel about it
but again your attitude is just doing
whatever it takes
i wouldn't judge you for it you know i
probably wouldn't necessarily encourage
people to do that but i wouldn't judge
you for doing it because you did
whatever you needed to do
to get that bad boy filled in two weeks
yeah which you did
yeah i did yeah so and you also i like
the fact that you've got four rooms but
you were like
i want to rent it to one of the rooms to
a couple so i'm gonna get a license for
five people
you know maximizing your profits on
every given time
and another thing is a lot of people do
rent a rents but they do it wrong
and they might only make two or three
hundred pounds and they're messing
around
but you're making 1 600 pounds a month
clean profit off these just two
properties yeah
you've systemized it well you've got a
little maintenance team yeah i've got a
maintenance team professional cleaners
um so it's all it's all being fully
managed and 1 600 just to be clear
that's profit right net profit yeah
what's the
actual total turnover that your business
is collecting from the rents
um it's uh well it's uh
was it 5 900 pounds all right so just
shy of six crayons
but you're only keeping sixteen hundred
yeah they say turnover is
uh vanity profit is sanity but it must
feel pretty good to be making 1600 pound
a month coming in each month
yeah that must be a pretty good feeling
yeah for me that's uh
financial freedom it's more than
financial freedom because i don't have
much expenses
so i'm financially free now in property
which is allowing me now to focus on
getting more deals
yeah which is what i'm aiming for but
yeah
that's it wasn't uh hard to get the
rooms
tenanted uh with the right by doing it
the way i did
um i was getting sort of 15 messages
plus a day
and the landlady has got another couple
properties for you now
that's right so she's got another two
properties one being in chiswick
uh right next to the two two flats i've
got uh two apartments i've got and then
another
six bedroom house in elscourt which i'm
um
i'm waiting to agree she's just waiting
for the tenants to move out so
i can take over excellent you also got
another another landlord direct
i've got another landlord direct
actually on it on a
new build yeah in park royal which which
is in the negotiation stage um they've
agreed to work with me as a as a company
um now it's just
agreeing the right price so what's the
goal
i mean what are you hoping to achieve by
the end of 2021
i've got a huge goal i want to take on
another 20 rental rents this year
um so i'm working hard at getting there
which will get me to 22 rent to rent and
that's that's my main that's all i'm
focusing on for this year
and what's your strongest reason for
doing all this
my strongest reason is um getting my dad
out of
he's got his business um like basically
a car wash business he's working in it
so i want to get him
out of work i want him to he's worked
enough years now
and get him out of work so he can settle
down enjoy
his life with the family and
also i've got a dream and a target to
build an empire
um so yeah that that's
what drive the thing that drives me is
is getting my
my family completely financially free
yeah settle down
has anyone else in your family like done
this before
no no they haven't they like i've got my
i've got family relatives uh i don't
want to say any names but
they've done buy to let's right just a
standard
buy a property wait save up buy a
property wait
20 years whatever yeah sell it and
they've done that but this is completely
different yeah that's a slow
way to get financial freedom you know
like you're making more money
1600 pounds of these two properties than
most people would do if they actually
just went and bought the properties
yeah because you know how to control it
and profit from it
so yeah that's fabulous words of advice
on watching this
what would you say to someone that wants
to emulate what you've done maybe
they're young
maybe they've not got the beard yet yeah
tips first
tip i'd say is um get a mentor someone
who's done it
you that's the most important thing or
you're going to save like i say
over a year's time by doing that second
thing
is follow the steps that your mentor
gives you
exactly the way they give it to you if
you're young
and you're and you're meeting the
landlords directly then i'd
bring someone older with you and maybe
someone with experience
in in that strategy that you're doing or
someone like a family member so
they can see your yeah you're a genuine
individual
um solid and take action yeah the laser
beam focused and take action
and again you don't have to necessarily
take your parents if your parents aren't
backing you
like take someone that's in property
that wants to just see you in
and mentoring it as well like it doesn't
have to be really really expensive
i mean my mentoring is 95 pound a month
yeah it's not a lot of money it's very
cheap
actually and you've got access to me
you've got access to a bunch of other
people that are financially free um
so it doesn't have to be like you don't
have to be spending tens of thousands of
pounds
but i agree with what you're saying get
some guidance get some support
the main issue and i can speak from
personal experience is that
people don't have enough self-esteem
they don't believe it enough in
themselves
so if if they um first
learn how to build self-confidence um
and believe that they're gonna achieve
what they
what they want to achieve yeah that's
the first step yeah then it's
finding the mentor and taking the action
yeah because now you're mentally
prepared
to do what it takes to get to where you
want to be i think that's really really
true
um so no no massive congrats on what
on what you've done so i can't wait to
see your empire
and um i i i don't know did you do well
in school
no founding school yeah well i wasn't
good in school no
i i just i never cared about school to
be honest
like i wouldn't even go to the exams i
was the naughty kid
oh you were annoyed yeah i was the
naughty so naughty kid started no money
spent two years thinking about it
watching youtube videos
failing miserably and now everything's
changed
winning financially free big heart so
dude thanks so much for coming on the
show
thanks for inviting me you're so welcome
every single week folks
i interview another success student i
don't know any other property training
company
in on the planet that does this you know
every week just interview someone
interview someone we got winners
wednesday interviews
booked up until the summer of 2021
so it works the process works the
training works
if you want to see more winners on our
wednesday stories check them out here
we've got over 100
interviews for the last couple of years
if you want to learn about how to get
mentored from samuel 365 or
the crash course i'll leave some links
in the description below
and also don't forget to subscribe right
here where you can see more videos every
single day thanks so much